- 1, 2, 3.
(upbeat music plays)
(yells)
- Dude I seriously regret my decision.
- I was talking (bleep) about the spice,
and now it's gotten me.
(music ends)
(air whooshes)
Hey, we're the cast of ONE PIECE,
and today we're going to
try some spicy candies.
I'm Mexican, so I kind of
grew up with spicy food.
If I'm not able to handle the spicy,
I'm gonna feel very
disappointed in myself.
(air whooshes)
So we have a spicy thing here.
- You should probably pick the one
that's least spicy for yourself.
- [Taz] I'd go green if I was you.
- This smells spicy-
- Green, docile.
- I'm just gonna grab the same one.
- Hey!
- Ah.
- Hmm.
- This is just nice.
It's not spicy at all.
(buzzer sounds)
- First candy was really easy.
Let's go for the second one huh?
- Woo.
- Oh okay.
Look at this.
- Yummy.
- Is it spicy?
Maybe I'm too spicy for this.
(both laughs)
1, 2, 3.
This is not spicy at all, guys.
- Mm hmm.
(buzzer bleeps)
- This is hot sweet.
- But it is good though.
- It's really good.
- I'm gonna have more.
- That's nice.
- Give us a challenge!
Here we go for the third spicy chest.
But I mean, is it really gonna be spicy?
Everything has been so easy so far.
Let's check it out.
Here girl.
- This is giving me
like childhood flashbacks
of the, like the birdie box.
- Oh God.
(Inaki sneezes)
- Yeah. Oh.
- [Taz] You mean like jelly beans?
(Inaki blows raspberry)
- Bless you.
- See, the spice getting to him.
- Bless you King.
- No.
Okay.
(coughs)
The spicy is attacking a little bit.
- Is it really?
- Alright. 1, 2, 3.
Let's eat.
- One, two.
- I already ate mine.
- What?
- Mine's already in there.
(Taz coughs and laughs)
- Oh, okay.
This is proper spicy now.
(meter whines)
- [Emily] It's a little spicy,
but it doesn't have good
flavor, which is a bummer.
- Yeah it's kind of just-
(meter continues whining)
- [Inaki] Oh.
like a little bit of pain, isn't it?
- Oh.
- [Jacob] I feel like there's
different levels of jelly bean
spice going on in this one.
(meter whines louder)
- [Taz] Yeah it's got levels.
- Oh, when you think
it's like different depending on-
- I think so.
- Wait, what color-
- Another color?
Should we try a different color?
- I tried the most devious looking one.
- I've tried both.
- The dark red one with
these little orange
- Mm hmm.
I actually hate jelly.
(Inaki coughs uncontrollably)
(Taz laughs)
- I'm gonna take one of each color.
- Our fearless leader.
- I was talking-
- You want more?
- [Taz] I think a handful would be-
- I was talking (bleep) about the spice,
and now it's gotten me.
(Jacob yells out)
(dramatic music plays)
- I choose one of each color.
- You should never speak too soon.
- Whoa.
- [Emily] Okay.
- All right let's go.
- Oh gosh Taz.
(suspenseful music plays)
Wow.
- I seriously regret my decision.
(explosion)
(alarm blares)
(Taz coughs uncontrollably)
(meter whines)
- It's an intense chewy experience-
- Bro who did this!
- In the mouth.
- Who created this thing?
(sad music plays)
I am sorry Mexico that I
disappointed you today.
I could not handle it.
(music stops)
Oh my gosh.
- You did great.
- Thank you Emily.
We tried.
- [Taz] There you go.
- Another one?
Okay.
I'll, I'll try.
(dramatic music plays)
I got this.
- [Emily] Alright.
- I'm gonna try to keep a
straight face while I eat this.
Let's see how it goes.
Three spicy candies.
Oh.
(upbeat music plays)
(air whooshes)
(alarm blares)
(everyone laughs)
(blows out air)
- Thanks for watching.
For a much sweeter time,
check out ONE PIECE
only on Netflix.
(everyone laughs)
- [Producer] You okay?